[Music]
well the raiders flew home sunday after
a bittersweet win in cleveland sports
director chris matthews
joining us now with more on why the team
isn't fully celebrating that big win
over the browns yeah kind of tough
denise here because the team won and
that's important for the franchise but
when a team is praying for another
teammate prior to the game because of a
medical incident
well then football certainly takes a
back seat raiders dedicated the game to
offensive lineman trent brown
he was in the locker room prior to and
suffered an undisclosed medical incident
nfl network reporting that it had
something to do with added oxygen in his
bloodstream due to an iv
the team revealing that brown is still
in cleveland for testing
but you get a sense from the raiders but
it was a scary moment
we don't know really anything about
trent status the most important thing
is that we find out what went wrong and
you know our prayers are with trent
certainly and he's in the best possible
hands he could be right now but
his availability and his status is
really not
up for discussion right now as far as
we're concerned boy it seems brown has
been snake bit since last season
injured came back injured again and
remember brown just contracted the covet
virus
about two weeks ago raiders traveled to
los angeles to meet the chargers this
sunday as you heard from the coach
no word on if brown will be allowed to
play in that game brian